- [Instructor] We are
told, "Drag the sliders."
And then they say, "Which
slider creates a scale
"copy of the shape?"
Or, "Which slider creates
scale copies of the shape?"
So let's just see and
explore this a little bit.
Okay, that's pretty neat,
these sliders seem to change
the shape in some way,
and in different ways.
So shape B right over
here, so it starts off,
it looks like the width
is a little bit bigger
than the height, I'm just
trying to eyeball it,
we don't know the exact numbers.
And so in order to create a scaled copy,
you'd want to scale the
width, you'd want to scale
this bottom side, and the top
side, and all of the sides.
You'd want to scale by the same factor.
But as we move this slider,
it seems like it's only
scaling the width, it's
not scaling the height.
So this slider, shape B right over here,
the slider for shape B is not creating
scale copies of itself, it's
only increasing the width,
not the height.
While shape A, it looks
like it is increasing
both the width and the height,
so that would be a scale copy.
So for example, that looks
like a scale copy of this,
which looks like a scale copy of this,
which looks like a scale copy of that,
which was our original shape.
That is not a scaled copy of this.
Let's do another example.
So once again they say,
"Drag the sliders."
And they say, "Which
slider creates a scale copy
"of the shape?"
All right, let's get shape A.
So this does look like we're scaling down,
but we're scaling both
the width and the height
by the same factor, so this shape A slider
does look like it's creating
scale copies of the shape.
B right over here, well
now we're only scaling,
it looks like we're
only scaling the height,
but not the width, so this
is not creating scale copies
of our original shape.
It's elongating it, it's
increasing its height,
but not the width.